so what am i pronouncing Indian names I
know nothing about that how the heck am
I supposed to pronounce Dorito the Reedy
it's like a little movie see that's how
you say it sounds like if I was a rapper
that would be like my car that I'm like
driving in hot ass to Riddhi everyday
the day VJ VJ like an MTV VJ of a
shinobi vice and ovulation Abbi oh come
on now that has Geneva Vice Navi seemed
like so close at all of these in so
close
Anushka it looks like a pronounced as a
new scar but I bet you it's way off
a new sky Anushka yeah I think I got
that one
Vivek Vivian I get Indian Vivian Vivek
Anika's Vivek shreya the musician's
musician guys the fake oh it's the guys
now normally it's like we need too many
letters
I'm not using them all but I feel like
this one could use a couple extra letter
I you sh see I want to say it's AI use
but I kind of think it's unusable I use
I use too many A's like Erin chuckling
gum oh my god what Chuck Chuck Chuck I
think of them chuckling God it sounds
dirty
the way that I said it it sounded like
I'm like a disease Matt to Lee my TV
Matsui
okay let's do you I mean that a there mi
might eat me wait got it cutter Carrie
Carrie
if it pronounced car a or or just car
that's very sexy
catarah maybe that sounds confidence
right it's all about confidence in how
you pronounce the name even if it's dead
wrong I think the names are very
beautiful pronunciation of names is
really important so even if it's like
super hard just try your hardest and
don't automatically go for the nickname
because that's someone's name you know
it's important
[Music]